basta fare un pagliaccio il pagliaccio
eccola lì youtube erode solita story e
mi seguite da tanto sapete che quando è
anita astori vuol dire che qualcosa
perché giocheremo un gioco pauroso
sempre di o blog se dobbiamo scappare
dagli incubi in ogni incubo c'è un
cattivo pauroso da pivot incubi non
siamo a scappare più punti accumuliamo e
potremmo anche vincere
ecco quali sotto casa dicendo che quasi
ora di andare a dormire
ecco la cassa come potete vedere molto
inquietante a me piace il nuovo altri
giallo giallo
eccolo qua dice buonanotte buonanotte
dormite bene praticamente da quello che
ho capito dalla storia e tipo un dottore
che sta facendo questi esperimenti e ci
fa fare gli in cui è già iniziata
superficie spongebob
in ogni incubo c'è un cattivo tipo
l'ascensore però il conto pagato un po
più difficile siamo in tantissimi vedi
vediamo proprio del mondo di quel
personale dove dove attento non farti
prendere ci sono le meduse vedi in
questo caso ci è capitato il mondo di
spongebob cattivo devo riuscire a
sopravvivere più incubi sopravviviamo
più abbiamo possibilità di meduse sono
prenderli con span poveretto che sta
picchiando volgare per agire per un
passo non sta interagendo con il vaso e
spesso 33 sacco di soldi
i ricettori io sono stata eliminata
veramente infatti sono giorni di sport
ovviamente lasciate un bel mi piace anzi
se questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace fare un altro episodio di
sopravvive agli incubi con i cattivi
guarito dalla rosa degli angeli per
niente sei riuscito a superare questo
incubo
vedi sopra gli stati e ci sei anche tu
onoriamo un po la casa sui santa e tipo
un castello dei fantasmi fanno un po
paura queste stanze
ecco i letti per dormire a sono sia qui
questa è l'aria vitro
ecco i netti porta dobbiamo scegliere un
letto andare a dormire e poi inizierà
poi l'incubo ok voi ogni letto c'è un
personaggio queste sono mie vieni qua
c'è una strega
il loro problema dove ha detto della
strega
prima di questo verde maccarini
cristiano dormendo ecco il dottore che
dice che sta per iniziare un nuovo
incubo
chi sarà il personaggio qua ma chi sono
dove sono io che non mi sento bene ma
stiamo limitando succede siamo in un
ospedale che cattivo klaus
vabbè io raccolgo le monete forse
riusciremo a ho capito che gli altri ti
sei al 3d vomitano addosso di fortitudo
20 uno di loro contagiata dai voglio
riuscire a sopravvivere almeno così cuba
che mi contattino il vomito aiuto sono
tutti stati cosa già uno o su una
cavalcata
abbiamo anche pochissimo forse sono
fatta proprio grazie alle sue ali 70
che curva diamo si giocherà a porta
sopravvissuti sì ci siamo entrambi e
anche tu per questo da questa pagina
ci sono i quadri con tutti i cattivi
guai abbiamo visto rafficato silp
andiamo si possono leggere libri tipo ma
è bellissima festa karate sete da
esplorare e mi sono accomodato qui si
diceva si accomodi sulla poltrona ma
anche se siete qua ormai un oggetto muro
lotta per iniziare un nuovo incubo
sei pronto se chi ci capiterà come
facciamo andare a dormire da subito e
dobbiamo andare lì le amiche siamo del
cacciatore di fantasmi
riposa in pace guardia è un fantasma n'è
visto poeti porro blues fantasma non
l'ho visto guarda eccitanti un fantasma
gigante vediamo rinunci ma tendono a
cosa dobbiamo fare
aiuto beh io prendo le monete come
sensore ci sono trenta persone che sono
scomparsi tenere non mi dire che
appariranno 30 cattivi ci abbiamo
possiamo spararlo guarda veramente una
brawn prende uno acquistare nella mira
spagnolo visto eliminato infatti ecco
infatti quella è la sua vita dove
possiamo farcela tutti assieme a che sta
scendendo se mancano ancora 18 secondi
dettagli uniamo le forze e dividiamo la
scappato aiuto
no non ce l'abbiamo fatta per poco un
peccato mancava poco per bambini durante
molto bravi
sì molto interessante questo gioco è un
po pauroso un po inquietante ma anche
divertente che volevo vedere tutti gli
incubi che vale germinare andare a
dormire quando nemmeno a mandare lacerna
bella ciao andare a letto con chi ti
capiterà questa volta prossimo incubo
ora 80 secondi sicuro che cos'è all'upi
allert alluvione e dobbiamo scappare da
qua si sta rimpianto tutto non ha
regalato aiuto se sta riempendo sotto di
questo blind verde
no peccato vitale ha già perso e chi
segue
anch'io sono morto posto proprio
purtroppo questo incubo è stato molto
ritirato molto poco io voglio vedere
tutti cattivi dei cattivi troppo
interessante guardate tutti i cattivi
quasi una strega questo è un ufo ma se
stai rende qualsiasi ma questo grasso
perché manovra non solo vaio all'ultimo
incubo non è sopravvissuto nessuno
allora davvero difficile
un po proprio a dormire qua dove sei
annabelle e matt bellamy papa che bello
il gatto giallo arrivando il prossimo
incubo brutti o mamma ma dove siamo
che succede non si vede niente ha
parlato per concedere una dilazione e il
cattivo quadrato e un aereo medici
scritto mario farina l'aereo dobbiamo
salvare i due sopravvissuti ma questi
aiuti c'è qualcuno non sembra avuto
michevole dove è meglio che non vai
nella foresta aiuto dai mancano pochi
secondi forse non sa proprio che io
minacciando 4k sopra qualcosa un albero
sarà visto dai tu che mi sa dire tu
passi un bellissimo sarò io adoro questi
quadri facce cartoon che guarda sono più
bello c'è scritto che è tempo di andare
a dormire mi devo andare al piano di
sopra nei letti prossimo incubo che
cos'è chi è il cattivo coar non si
capisce
c'è un coltello dunque questo
personaggio voi lo conoscete come si
chiama non capisco come si fa scappare
come si fa allora trovo al coltello
invece aiuto
ovviamente è tutto buio ancora più
inquietante è tutto buio
[Musica]
dobbiamo trovare il coltello perché si
mette sempre più buio dove è il
personaggio senso di a
ecco lo sente questo tutti il k io sto
scappando k aiuto che non mi son visto
aiuto mettendo mi stanno seguendo
dove sarà questo contenuto
mancano pochi secondi ma come pochi
secondi possiamo farcela sopravvivere
tutti siamo questo provvisti anche
questo incubo
andiamo subito a definire i ora dormo
qua dove c'è più alieno magari prossimo
incubo qualcuno che sta dietro in una
gabbia con un giorno speciale in
programma perché no un pagliaccio il
pagliaccio eccolo lì dove lo stato
eliminato già tantissime persone
velocissimo kk non mi scorderò e
dobbiamo liberare quella persona
poverina ma che cosa sono queste cose
del cielo
non capisco proprio quelli con il laser
come facciamo a liberarlo ecco il pari a
ciò perché giuseppe tutto ma correndo
questo ciò che ho visto a passare
semplici cambia lo guarda vogliamo
trovare il passaggio in viola per
riuscito a liberare questa persona forse
dentro la tenda andando andiamo amore ma
che non sia partito no mi dispiace non
essere riuscito a salvarlo manualmente
questo provviste ciechi
e ora ultimo in cui vediamo che sarà
meter a questa volta cos'è questo
youtube 18 bambini stanno arrivando
dalla terra città è sotto attacco
combattiamo la città è sotto attacco
dagli ufo ma tv sparate alla navicella
non avevo visto che c'era una dieta è
stato guarito non iniziamo rita dalla
rosa degli angeli forse ma eccoli gli
alieni sono offrirà un film per noi ei
ma non si rompeva è questa qui la mente
dai l'uomo non è la navicella sito
mondiali a un giù in strada gli alieni
si sono qui in strada e forse era errato
l'anno è stato aperto del ricevuto tre
oggetti caso anni e gettoni wow
grazie al grido di verbali dai facciamo
l'ultimo incubo bene così qua stiamo
dormendo sta per iniziare il prossimo
incubo che sarà l'ultimo incubo speriamo
di sopravvivere ancora viviamo e ultimo
piano facciamo in modo che sia chiaro
vattene fuori dice aiuto aiuto che
succede dove siamo a metà abbiamo così
le abbiamo vari oggetti qua sembra che
possiamo sparare ma dobbiamo sparare non
c'è un mostro gigante e tipo nothomb
eccolo quindi lo zombie il mostro qua
penso che ci contagerà lo stesso
dobbiamo riuscire a beccarlo si è troppo
veloce velocissimo casey è riuscita
valuto se lo peccato proprio mancano
pochi secondi ma è difficilissimo
eliminarlo siamo sopravvissuti a 10
incubi e abbiamo fatto io ho fatto 501
punti e tu 397 sono sopravvissuta 8
raccomandate volete una seconda parte
degli incubi lasciato un bel mi piace e
ora via sacco a quattro casellina su cui
cliccare per vedere inoltre altri video
licata su quella che preferite
visione ciao